hello I'm so nervous today because I
have a something that I need to tell you
I have a secret basically that I've been
keeping from you for quite a while it is
probably going to change the way you
perceive me just you know forever but I
feel like we've known each other for a
while now and that we're at the stage in
our relationship where I just I just
have to be honest with you well bat and
I don't really have any choice in the
matter to be honest in fact I don't
really have any notions about what
choice actually is I just do what I'm
told
basically I am and have always been a
robot hello everyone my name is Artie
Bloch
I am a robotics technician and I am the
chief developer on the Charlie bot
project and I'm here today we're here
today to announce to you finally what
many of you have speculated about over
the years that Charlie McDonnell or
Charlie but is in fact a machine are you
buddy
now we're the Charlie bot has been in
development for about eight years now so
before even YouTube was around and he
was originally created for the US
military as a robot soldier with
superhuman strength unfortunately there
were some slight complications there and
he was later repurposed for the use of
light entertainment now one of the
things you might have noticed about the
Charlie videos is the use of a jump cut
editing for example and that style
actually comes out of a technical issue
that we have with the Charlie but if you
let me demonstrate
basically the Charlie bot can only say
so much before it overheats so if I
program in a couple of messages for it
to say okay hello I'm Charlie and this
is me saying something as if I was a
real person which of course I'm not
then he automatically freezes and what
we do is we reposition him reactivate
him and then he says the second liner
did you know that it's a piece of cake
to bake a pretty cake what and then Gary
your video editor cuts out that bit in
the middle and that's how we ended up
with the Charlie jump cut stone now the
exciting news we have for you today
the reason we're even doing this is that
Apple have recently acquired the Charlie
bot and with that one
to release a brand new consumer model of
the charlie box areas and it comes with
all of the features you would expect
from the the Charlie and the videos plus
some new ones which which which are
program charlie to say whatever you like
yes yes I will marry you insert name
here watches he calculates anagrams
chicken an anagram of chicken is check
in simpleton an anagram of simpleton is
lemon spit nerimon an anagram of
Merriman is Iron Men if you have an iPod
then you can use him as a speaker using
for security for when you're out of the
house he also comes with a variety of
different t-shirts including the classic
no Pogo cloning Charlie I got opinions
Captain Hammer and will also be
releasing one with purple skin though
that's still in production he is
completely anatomically correct and yes
you will be able to program him to love
you and he's fairly cheap too for
advanced robotics only about one or one
or two million so it's not really that
steep I'm sure you built it love to get
with your friends to get one thanks for
watching everyone so yeah thank you
thank you very much for watching hope
you liked Charlie bot I hope you buy one
and if you have any thoughts about him
then please do get in touch now once
again my name is Artie Bloch an anagram
of Artie Bloch is Charlie BOTS I'm sorry
what did you just say hold on let me get
you two repeats lost Missy an anagram of
Artie Bloch is Charlie BOTS
you're one of us now charlie I'm a
Charlie BOTS
[Music]
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool